[Music]
let's talk about the fact that this is a
night for the Irwin's to get glammed up
what is it like to go from khaki and the
Outback to glam on the red carpet blog
Robert because he managed to find dress
up kaki exactly yes I'm still in my car
keys but yeah a little bit more formal
I've got a little bow tie which is good
so but you know it's I'm still cocky
ready I'm so ready to wrangle animals so
it's good what would Steve have worn on
a red carpet would he have gone in the
style of Robert or just stuck to the
regular outfit oh no just regular yes
regular I remember when Steve was
invited to present an award at the
BAFTAs and they said you have to wear a
tuxedo just gonna wear my khakis yeah
strong in those khakis that fit it is
definitely not just a color you guys
have had so many great moments the past
couple of weeks the walk of fame star
and then being here tonight
conversations have you had about just
getting to have these really awesome
emotional moments where you're honoring
Steve yeah I think it's more emotional
than we expected hey pindy and it's been
it's been so special I mean it's kind of
in this wonderful moment after another
so we had to have star which was just a
brilliant moment in time and then Robert
was on The Tonight Show with Jimmy
Fallon showcasing all of these gorgeous
animals and now the gala dinner and then
we fly home and film with Animal Planet
so it's all coming together beautifully
and I feel like this is just a gorgeous
new chapter of our lives and it's just
it feels like the right time for
everything so tonight it's gonna be a
wonderful celebration of everything that
Dad achieved together with people who
really like minded just genuinely
passionate about wildlife and
conservation and making a difference so
you guys have all been spending a lot of
time together Chandler's been with you
every step of the way what do you think
Dad would have thought of that great guy
oh I I hope you'd liked him I think he
would I mean Tail is wonderful he's
always up for the challenge from jumping
on crocodiles to getting his little
cocky bow tie on you know he's doing
good so I hope
and you know we all love him so I don't
know what do you think about Mike I
think I think he's great I think I think
your dad would have tested him yeah
morning noon and night and then approved
because your dad was kind of like that
dad always used to say if you're gonna
date a guy he has to cross the kruk pond
fast like swim across the cross fun and
thankfully Chandler was awake border so
you know what wakeboarding across the
crockpot
I'm sure he would have pasta death would
it well
[Music]